>>Female Presenter: Hello and welcome. My
name is Alana Weiss. I'm part of Google EDU
and today it is my honor to welcome Barry
Schwartz to the Leading at Google series.
Barry is a professor of psychology at Swarthmore
College and he's been teaching there since
1971 upon the completion of his PhD at the
University of Pennsylvania.
He's the author of ten books and hundreds
of articles and he's actually been to Google
before. Because in 2004, he published a book
entitled "The Paradox of Choice: Why More
is Less." And his TED Talk on that book is
actually how I learned of his work and became
very excited.
And he is here today to speak about his newest
book, "Practical Wisdom." Please join me in
welcoming Barry. Thank you.
[applause]
>>Barry Schwartz: Thanks. Hi everybody. It's
really a pleasure to be here. And it's also,
of course, a little intimidating, but I'll
try to suppress my terror. I decided that
what I would do is combine the stuff that
I have already written about on Choice very
quickly, just in case there's somebody out
here who doesn't already know something about
it, but focus mostly on the new work on "Practical
Wisdom."
So the title of the talk is "Practical Wisdom:
The Choices that Matter," because the book
on choice was all about how when you give
people too much choice, it leads to all kinds
of bad results. And what I'm gonna focus on
today is how when you give people too little
choice, it leads to all kinds of bad results.
And in addition, the Choice stuff is really,
from my point of view, about how Google relates
to the rest of the world, at least as far
as you're concerned. It's really about what
Google needs to do actually succeed in serving
its clients and giving us, the rest of us,
what we need.
The Practical Wisdom is really much more about
how Google works with Google. It's really
about how organizations need to be structured
and how they need to run in order to allow
people to do their best work. So, this is
a more inward-looking, at least from my point
of view, focus.
OK. So, the official syllogism in the US and
pretty much every other Western country runs
roughly like this: We can't ever have too
much freedom; the more freedom people have
the better off they are; we should take every
opportunity to enhance freedom when we can.
If we agree to that and pretty much everyone
does, the question is how do you enhance freedom?
And the answer is obvious. You can't enhance
freedom without giving people choice. So,
more freedom means more well-being. And more
choice means more freedom.
And so it follows as the night, the day, that
the more choice people have the better off
they are. This seems to me to be almost unassailable.
It's logically powerful. The only trouble
is that it is psychologically false; it ain't
true. And the research that I and others have
done in the last ten or fifteen years, has
shown that when people have too much choice,
bad stuff happens.
And again, I'm gonna do this very fast. The
first bad thing that happens is that people
are paralyzed. With everything at their disposal,
they can't pull the trigger. Instead of being
liberated by all this choice, they're paralyzed
by all this choice. The second bad thing that
happens if they overcome paralysis and choose
they are likely to choose badly.
People make bad decisions even in simple environments.
Well, you can just imagine how much worse
the decisions are when the environments get
complex and let me assure you that choosing
among 60 or 70 Medicare Part D prescription
drug plans is complex enough to challenge
anyone, even the people in this room, let
alone their aging grandparents and parents.
The third bad thing that happens is if you
overcome paralysis and choose and if you get
lucky and you choose well, you end up, people
end up less satisfied with good choices if
they're chosen from large choice sets than
if they're chosen from small ones. It is always
easy to imagine when you encounter any imperfection
in any item or activity that you have chosen.
It is easy to imagine that some alternative
out there would've been better. And so, you
compare how good the thing is with how good
you expected it to be and you end up disappointed.
So, psychologists have known for 40 or 50
years that choice is good. And yet, my stuff
has emphasized the ways in which choice is
bad.
So how can choice be good and bad? And the
way I have conceptualized it is that the relation
between the amount of choice people have and
how they feel looks roughly like this curve.
And just so that you're clear, the curve does
not actually capture real data.
It's an idealization. But the point is that
all the way on the left, when people have
no choice, life is infinitely bad. You can't
live a human life and not have significant
choice.
However, as you add choice and you make life
better and better and better, a point is reached
where all of the benefits of choice essentially
asymptote, flatten out, and all of the negative
consequences of too much choice start to rear
their ugly heads and the curve changes direction.
To be technical, the relation between choice
and well-being is non-monotonic. And the task
is to figure out the point in a choice space
where people can derive all of the benefits
without paying the substantial psychological
cost. So, if the curve looks like I just described
it to you, the question you face as a provider
of options to people is what's the right amount
of choice?
So, one task that people face, whether it's
supermarkets, clothing retailers, or information
providers, is what's the sweet spot? How many
options is the right amount of options for
people to derive the benefits of having choice
without paying the price?
And the sad fact is that there is no algorithmic
way to answer that question. I'm afraid the
way you figure out what the sweet spot is,
is by studying people making decisions in
different domains. The sweet spot is likely
to be different in different areas of life.
Finding the sweet spot however, is enormously
important. The second thing you can do and
I think Google does this remarkably well is
you separate the principle from the agent.
That is to say, you have an agent who curates
the choice space.
And even though there may be hundreds and
hundreds of options, the principle, the person
who's going to actually have to make the choice,
only sees three or four. And you have wisely
structured the choice domain and filtered
out options so that not only does the principal
only see three or four, but it's just the
right three or four.
And it doesn't matter under those conditions
how many options are out there because the
only ones that the principal sees are the
ones that matter. And the last thing that
you can do is pay attention to what economist
Richard Thaler and law professor Cass Sunstein
refer to as "choice architecture."
Pay attention to how options are structured
so that you make it as easy as possible for
people to make, to choose at all, and to choose
well. And the most important characteristic
of choice architecture is to pay attention
to what happens when people do nothing.
People do nothing a lot. They're busy. They're
distracted. They're overwhelmed. They do nothing.
In a study of organ donation, 90-something
percent of Americans approve of organ donation.
Twenty-six percent of Americans are organ
donors, right? One-quarter of the people in
the United States who think organ donation
is a good idea are actually organ donors.
If you look in Europe where they also use
driver's license renewal as an opportunity
to get organ donors, you see that there are
many countries in Europe where virtually everyone
is an organ donor. And there are a few that
look like the United States.
So, what's the difference between the countries
on the left and the countries on the right?
The difference is the countries on the right:
you are an organ donor unless you opt out.
The countries on the left, like the United
States, you are not an organ donor unless
you opt in.
Paying attention to what happens when people
do nothing is a major, major opportunity to
help people make good choices. The same thing
has been shown with 401Ks. The standard procedure
with 401K participation is that you have to
give your employer permission to withhold
some money and otherwise, everything comes
to you and there's no savings for retirement.
If you switch the default so that money is
automatically withheld from your paycheck,
unless you tell the employer not to, you triple
the rate of 401K participation. So this is
merely one example of how, rather than imposing
solutions on people and eliminating choice,
which would after all be un-American.
You give people options, but you structure
the options so that people are nudged in the
direction that you have independent reason
to believe is the direction that they would
choose. And so, as a provider of quote "all
of the world's information," you have an enormous
opportunity to do precisely this, basically
with the results of every search anyone ever
does.
You nudge people in the right direction. Make
it hard for them to go in the wrong direction.
People are nonetheless free to look at the
75,000, 822nd ranked result of a Google search
if they want to, but you're making it easy
for them to look at the results that are most
likely to be the results they care about,
as long as you do it right.
And there are millions of opportunities to
make nudges like this. I just read a paper
three days ago. We have an obesity problem
in the United States. I assume you're all
aware of it. Although, apparently, there's
no obesity problem at Google, despite the
infinite availability of food.
So, it turns out that people are much more
likely to choose items from the top of a menu
list or the bottom of a menu list than they
are items in the middle. You can't force people
to eat healthy, but if you put all the really
poisonous stuff in the middle of the menu,
you will decrease the chances that people
order it.
And there are nudges like this available almost
everywhere you look. None of them depriving
people of freedom of choice, all of them helping
people to make better choices. So that was
what the Choice book was about, how we have
too much choice and what we can do about it.
Now I wanna focus on my current work, which
is about how we have too little choice. What
prompted this book, and it's written with
my colleague Ken Sharp, who teaches political
science at Swarthmore. What prompted this
book was the sense that Ken and I have had
for quite some time that America is, in some
important respects, broken.
And what I mean by that is that our kid's
teachers don't know our kids well enough,
we think, to give each of them what they need.
And they don't seem to care enough to find
out what our kids need. Our doctors rush through
office visits in seven minutes, hardly having
the opportunity to get to know us.
And increasingly, at least I find this, our
office visits to the doctor are mostly spent
with you watching as the doctor stares at
the laptop and enters data in response to
the questions that you get asked. Lawyers
pursue billable hours and seldom ask whether
what we think we need and want is what we
should need and want and of course, the bankers.
Bankers nearly wrecked the world economy and
it seems to me the jury is still out about
whether the world economy will be saved. Nothing
in America seems to work the way it should.
Now, historically, when we encounter institutions
that don't work well, don't give us what we
need, don't give us what we want, we have
two tools that we reach for to solve the problem.
One tool is rules: more and more rules; more
and more detailed rules; closer and closer
regulation. The other tool is incentives.
If we can find a way to create smart incentives
so that people do well by doing good, the
system will take care of itself.
Some combination of rules and incentives is
the magic solution to the problem of inadequate
schools, overly expensive and inadequate health
care, shyster lawyers, and corrupt, greedy
bankers. If only we can find the right rules
and the right incentives. The theme of our
book is that neither rules nor incentives
will get us what we need.
They are blunt instruments and in fact, they
actually get in the way of getting us what
we need. So, what we need is character. And
in particular, we need an aspect of character
that Aristotle called "practical wisdom."
That I'm going to try to explain to you very
quickly what that is and how every effort
we currently make to make things better in
our social institutions is actually making
them worse.
So, let me talk to you about a janitor named
Luke, who works at a major medical center
in the Midwest. These are the characteristic
duties of hospital janitors in this particular
medical center. Don't memorize them. There
won't be an exam. But if you scan them, it
should be clear that none of these things
is the least bit surprising.
They're just what you would imagine. Here
are more of them. It may surprise you that
there are so many items on the list, but not
what the items are. So, this is Luke and Luke's
colleagues job description.
And yet, psychologists who interviewed Luke
and his colleagues about their work and how
they saw their work and what was important
about their work would hear stories like the
one that Luke told of how he had cleaned the
room of a patient, a young man who was comatose
after a bar fight.
And the young man's father was keeping a vigil.
He was there in the hospital all day, every
day, but he smoked, this guy. So he would
occasionally go out to wherever he could smoke
to have a cigarette. And so, Luke cleaned
this man's room and the dad didn't see Luke
clean this man's room and he confronted Luke
irate and demanded that he clean the room.
And Luke. What did Luke do? Well, he said,
"I could've told him that I cleaned the room.
I could've gotten angry because he was being
so disrespectful. But, you know, he was a
man who was trying to do something, anything,
to help his son. So, I just cleaned the room
again."
Luke's interest was in serving the needs of
the patient and the patient's family. None
of that was in his job description. He did
it effortlessly. He did it immediately. And
it was things like that that made Luke eager
to show up for work every day. It wasn't emptying
trash cans.
It was being part of a mission of easing suffering
and providing comfort to people in distress.
And Luke was not unique. There was another
case of a guy who was sweeping the, washing
the floor in the hallway and a patient who
had just recovered , had just been operated
on was slowly and with great difficulty getting
out of bed to move a little bit up and down
the hall to speed the healing.
And he stopped washing the floor so that the
patient could actually do this little bit
of exercise without slipping and falling.
There was another janitor, Charlane, who was
told she had to clean the visitor's lounge
and she went to the lounge and noticed that
there were four or five people, members of
the same family, who were there again, day
after day and night after night.
And they happened to be napping. And so, she
refrained from cleaning the visitor's lounge
so that she wouldn't disturb them, even brooking
disapproval from her supervisor. So, these
are the characteristics of janitors and their
work that they regard as most important, even
though there is not a single item on their
list of duties that even mentions another
human being.
They are crafting their work so as to contribute
to the mission of the hospital. And they are
doing it wisely. Obviously, there are times
when patients want them to do something when
they have to back away because it requires
a kind of expertise that they don't have.
They need to know when to go forward and when
to back off. And they learned how to do this
by basically having lots of experience working
with and around sick people. The second example
is of a judge. Judge Lois Forer. And she was
a judge in the Common Pleas Court in Philadelphia
and she reports the case of a young man named
Michael, who committed an armed robbery.
He had just lost his job. He had a wife and
a six-year old child, with great difficulty
they were managing to send away to a parochial
school. And he had just lost his job. He had
a little bit too much to drink. He was feeling
desperate. He got into a taxi and he held
up the taxi driver with a toy gun.
He got 50 dollars. He was caught. There was
no question of his guilt. And the question
that Forer faced is what should the sentence
be? There is a sentence for committing armed
robbery in a public conveyance of five years
in prison. That's what she could have sentenced
him to.
She thought that was preposterous. He had
no criminal history. He was acting in a state
of desperation. He seemed to be a dedicated
family person. And so, she sentenced him to
eleven months in jail with release every day
to go to work. So he got up, went to work,
spent the day in the workplace, came back
and slept in jail.
After eleven months, he was released on probation.
Went back to his family, got another job,
family stayed united, everything seemed to
be fine, except that the prosecutor couldn't
live with that incredibly lenient sentence
and appealed the sentence.
And after the wheels of justice ground as
slowly as they do, the prosecutor won the
appeal and Michael was required to serve out
the remaining four years and one month of
his sentence. Michael disappeared and Lois
Forer quit. She couldn't be a judge when being
a judge meant that you couldn't use your judgment.
And so, what Lois Forer was trying to do was
be a wise judge. What Luke and his colleagues
in the hospital were trying to do is to be
wise custodians. And what it means to be wise
from Aristotle's point of view is to combine
two things. One is the will to do the right
thing, to provide what people need.
Which, of course, depends on what domain you're
operating in. The other is to have the skill
to figure out what the right thing is. And
that takes skill because there's no formula
to tell Lois Forer what the right sentence
is in any given case. And there's no formula
to tell the custodians how to intervene on
behalf of patients.
Wise people know when and how to make the
exception to every rule. Wise people know
when and how to improvise. We talk about wisdom
as a kind of moral jazz. There are notes on
the page, if you like. Those are the rules,
but they're just guidelines. And what makes
great jazz is not that you play the notes
on the page, it's how you deviate from the
notes on the page. You can do that well or
you can do that badly. Wise people are good
jazz musicians. Wise people know how to find
the mean, which is not the arithmetic average.
It's what Aristotle had in mind when he talked
about how courage was the mean between cowardice
and recklessness.
Now where is the mean between cowardice and
recklessness? The answer is: it depends. It
depends on the context. It depends on the
circumstances. There is no formulaic way to
figure out what the mean is. Wise people know
how to choose among virtues when they conflict.
Imagine a doctor who believes that doctors
be honest with patients.
Who doesn't believe that? The doctor also
believes that doctors should be kind with
patients. Well, it turns out that sometimes
being honest tells you to do one thing and
being kind tells you to do another. How do
you balance two legitimate, important, but
conflicting aspirations, conflicting values?
Wise people figure out how to do it and the
point of balance, again, as Aristotle emphasized,
depends on who you're dealing with, what the
circumstances are. Wise people know how to
put themselves in other people's places. They
can see the world as other people see the
world.
And they can feel what other people are feeling.
Empathic understanding is an essential ingredient
of wisdom. It's something that takes experience
to learn. Little kids have the impulse to
be empathetic, but they don't have a clue
about what would actually help.
There's this great story about a two-year
olds at nursery school and one of their classmates
is upset and crying and it bothers them, so
they wanna help this unhappy two-year old.
So the question is what should they do? And
the answer they come up with is this.
"When I'm unhappy, I want a hug from my mom."
And so they walk over to this unhappy two-year
old, take her hand, and walk her over to their
mom. "A hug from my mom makes me feel better."
[inaudible words]
Would you mute whatever that is?
Is this the Giants game or something? No.
Thank you. "A hug from my mom makes me feel
better when I'm unhappy, so a hug from my
mom will make anyone feel better when they're
unhappy."
They have the impulse to ease the suffering
of others, but they don't have a clue about
what it takes to do that. Most of us, arguably
are a little better than two-year olds, but
it takes experience really to get good at
that. And perhaps most important, a wise person
uses these skills in pursuit of the right
aims, to serve other people and not to serve
him or herself.
If you use all of these skills to serve yourself,
you become a Machiavellian manipulator and
that's not what Aristotle thought a virtuous
person was like. And last, a wise person is
made, not born. We argue in the book that
everybody has the capacity to develop these
characteristics, but it takes experience.
It takes trial and error. It takes making
mistakes and getting wiser as a result of
learning from your mistakes. Nobody is born
with the magic gift of wisdom. So, the wise
doctor balances honesty, kindness, and kindness,
paternalism and patient autonomy. Let me tell
you what to do.
You decide what to do. A wise lawyer balances
passionate advocacy and judicious counsel.
A wise teacher or parent balances the fairness
with giving each child what she needs; that
is to say, treating kids differently. And
the question is what does the wise Googler
do?
I hope if there's time for some questions,
you'll contribute to the answer to that question.
I have a few suggestions, but I'm not gonna
give them to you yet, 'cause otherwise, you'll
just leave. So, we need, the argument in the
book is that there is no substitute for wisdom,
for the will to do the right thing, and the
skill to figure out what that is.
Nonetheless, what we are doing in American
society is engaging in a war on wisdom without
realizing that we're doing it. And we're engaging
in the war, both on the development of skill
and the development of will. What rules do,
rigid scripts do, is they prevent people from
improvising.
They prevent people from engaging in trial
and error and making mistakes and getting
better. You follow the script that some person
smarter than you has handed you. And the result
is that you never get any wiser after ten
years than you were on your first day.
I can give you a great example of this. This
is the lemonade story about a professor of
anthropology at the University of Michigan
who took his son to a Detroit Tigers game.
This boy was seven years old and he wanted
some lemonade. So dad got up to the concession
stand to buy his son some lemonade.
All they had was Mike's Hard Lemonade. Dad
had no idea what that was and so he bought
it and he brought it back. And there was this
kid drinking out of a bottle of Mike's Hard
Lemonade. A security guard saw it and immediately
called the police and an emergency ambulance
team.
They rushed to the stadium, got the boy, whisked
him off to the hospital, checked him out.
Turned out he was fine. His blood alcohol
level was negligible. They were all set to
release the child and the welfare officers,
who were also summoned to the scene, said,
"Not so fast. What we have here is a case
of child abuse. We will not allow the child
to go back to the home."
And so they put the child in a foster home.
A week or so later, the case came before a
judge and the welfare worker said, "We hate
to do it, but we have to follow procedure."
A week later, the case came before a magistrate
who said, "Well, here's what I'll do. I'll
let the boy go home, but only if Dad leaves
the house and checks into a hotel. I hate
to do it, but we have to follow procedure."
After three weeks, I'm happy to say the family
was reunited and for all I know this seven
year old kid now works here. The point though,
is that every step along the way from the
police to the child welfare agency to the
judge, the answer to the question was always
the same: "I hate to do it, parenthesis, I
know this is stupid, closed parenthesis, but
we have to follow procedure."
Judge Forer, as I said, was required to follow
procedure and changed Michael's sentence and
the result she found so intolerable that she
quit. And then there's education. If we think
we don't have teachers who are smart enough
to figure out how to teach, what we do is
we give them scripts so that they don't have
to figure out how to teach.
And here's an example from a Chicago kindergarten.
Every kindergarten teacher in the City of
Chicago was doing exactly the same thing on
Day 53. "Reading and enjoying literature/words
with 'b'. The bath." This is instructions
to the teacher. The instructions are 20 pages
long.
The book is 30 pages long. "Assemble students
on the rug or reading area. Give students
a warning about the dangers of hot water.
Say quote 'Listen very quietly as I read the
story.' Say, 禅hink of other pictures that
make the same sound as the sound bath begins
with.'"
And so, we routinize procedure that people
follow so as to protect students or patients
from disaster. But when we do that, we virtually
guarantee that all they're going to get at
best is mediocrity. There is no script that's
the right script for every kid. When you give
teachers a script, you're guaranteeing that
you will miss fit many of the students that
the script is being used on.
In addition, you deprive teachers of the opportunity
actually to become teachers. They never get
better at what they do because they don't
have the room, the space, to learn what works
and what doesn't work. And this is what we
have done increasingly and what we have appealed
to to try to fix all the institutions that
seem to be falling short.
So, if you're not gonna just rely on rules,
how about if we create smart incentives? Make
it worthwhile for teachers to improve test
scores. You know, the higher kids' test scores
get, the better the teacher's salaries are.
They get bonuses. They get all kinds of other
perks.
Let's make it worth their while and then they'll
work their asses off to get the kids to do
better on tests. Some of you may have read
recent scandal in Georgia public schools.
The teachers seem to have discovered, and
principals, have discovered one way to enable
kids to do better on standardized tests.
And that is by changing the kid's answers;
massive, massive cheating scandal in Georgia
public schools. So far, at least 175 teachers
have been implicated. So, this is not about
a bad apple. This is about a very rotten barrel.
And one of the things that produces this rotten
barrel is the incentive structure that currently
operates in education.
I'll give you one example of this because
I love it so much and it concerns a day care
center in Israel that was being troubled because
parents were coming late to pick up their
kids. They just couldn't tear themselves away
from the incredibly interesting work they
were doing.
So there was a temptation, you exhort the
parents to come on time. It's disrespectful.
They were still coming late. There's a temptation
to close the center up and just leave kids
sitting on the street, but somehow the director
thought that that was inhumane. And so he
figured the only way to get these people to
show up when they should is to make it cost
them to come late.
So he introduced fines, lateness fines. They
were roughly the equivalent of a parking ticket.
And guess what happened when parents were
fined for coming late?
>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER#1: They got angry.
>>Barry Schwartz: They didn't get angry. More
people came late.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #2: Because it was
fair.
>>Barry Schwartz: Not because, because it
was a price. You said it was a fine. I think
it's a price. It's a price worth paying. Is
it worth 15 bucks for me to spend another
half hour in the office? Damn right it is.
And so month after month went by with these
fines in place and the curve of lateness kept
going up and up and up, and finally in despair,
the director of the day care center discontinued
the fines. And now what do you think happened
to lateness?
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #3: It stayed high.
>>Barry Schwartz: It got even higher.
[laughter]
Because now it was a better deal.
Here's the important thing to, now, could
you have come up with a fine that would've
worked? Of course, ten years in prison for
coming ten minutes late. That would probably
get people, that would focus the mind, but
reasonable penalties didn't work.
And here was the logic behind the imposition
of penalties. People already have one reason
to come on time. They have an obligation.
They have a responsibility, a moral and social
responsibility. Let's give them a, that apparently
isn't strong enough. Let's give them a second
reason.
Now it'll cost them. Two reasons to do something
have to be stronger than one. Yes? Well, no.
'Cause what happens is that the second reason
completely undermines the first. Coming on
time loses any moral content at all. It is
simply a matter cost/benefit calculation.
And then once that seems to have happened,
it looks like it permanently eliminates the
social and moral sanctions on showing up on
time to pick up your kid, because when you
eliminate the fines it's not like your sense
of obligation perks back up.
It seems like you have transformed parental
behavior and the motivation behind it so that
it has become now just about "what's in my
best interest? What am I willing to pay?"
And that's a disaster. Big tests in schools
have, I won't talk about nuclear waste dumps
'cause I don't have enough time.
It's basically the same story. Well, I will.
I can do it in two sentences. You ask people
in Switzerland if they'd be willing to have
a nuclear waste dump in their community. Fifty
percent of people say yes. I assume the United
States would get the same response.
You ask people if they'd be willing to have
a nuclear waste dump in their community if
you paid them six weeks' salary a year. Now,
25% of people say yes. No pay--50%. Substantial
pay, 25%. Why? Because you have implicitly
instructed people to think about this as a
matter of self-interest rather than as a matter
of citizen responsibility.
And when they're thinking about it as a matter
of self-interest, it is self-evidently true
to them that it is not in their interest to
have a nuclear waste dump in their community
no matter what they get paid. Bonuses in the
financial sector.
Thirty years ago, smart economists, that's
not an oxymoron. Smart economists had this
idea that the way to get companies performing
well is to give leaders of companies a significant
portion of their compensation in the form
of stock options and bonuses.
Now when you get to the pinnacle of Google
or IBM or GE, you won't sit back, semi-retire,
and have four-hour lunches because how much
you earn is gonna depend on how well the company
does. It seems blindingly obvious now, since
that's the way everybody gets paid, but it
was an insight then.
And it was an insight that inspired confidence
that the market was now going to be completely
self-regulated. You were making it so that
people could only do well by doing good things
for their companies; a revolution in engineering
workplace organization.
It is exactly that revolution that produced
the concern for how well a company is doing
quarter by quarter, or month by month, or
week by week, or even minute by minute, so
that CEOs consistently made decisions that
sold the long-term well-being of their companies
down the river in return for profitable quarters.
This financial revolution turned out to bring
in its wake a financial disaster.
[Barry Schwartz clears throat]
So here are just some examples of what happens
when you demoralize the workplace. Now, you
might think that there's no such thing as
a banker who wants to do the right thing.
Yeah, doctors want to do the right thing.
Doctors want to cure disease and ease suffering.
Teachers want to stimulate young minds. Lawyers
wanna pursue justice, but what the hell do
bankers wanna do except get rich? Well it
turns out even bankers, at least historically,
while certainly interested in doing well for
themselves, also saw themselves as performing
a vital function for their communities.
They were revered members of their communities.
They enabled people to buy houses. They enabled
people to start businesses or expand businesses.
They were deeply respected. They wanted a
profit, but they wanted a reasonable profit
and they earned the respect of their communities.
You can still find bankers like this, but
they tend to work in very small banks, banks
that are community banks. They get up every
day knowing that at the end of the day somebody's
life will have been made better. It's not
clear to me that any of the bankers we read
about on a daily basis these days in the financial
pages think that there is any point at all
to banking except for maximizing return on
investment.
And that just doesn't cut it. OK. So, too
many rules undermine the development of the
skill that you need to be wise and too much
reliance on incentives undermines the will
that you need to be wise. And again, all of
these efforts to reform systems were well-intentioned.
They were not designed to make the systems
worse. They were designed to make the systems
better. And they may make the systems better
in the short run, but they create a problem
which guarantees that the systems will be
worse in the long run. So, what about wise
Googlers?
So, "don't be evil" is just not enough. It's
better to have that watch-word than not to
have it. I agree. But all that does is tell
you what not to do. And it's sometimes useful
to have negative instructions. Know what pitfalls
to avoid. But the question is what should
you be doing?
What is it that Google can do or you can do
that actually improves the quality of life
of individuals and the quality of life in
a whole society? This is an extremely important
question that should always be at the forefront
of your minds. Focus on the user. What does
your user want?
And more important from my point of view,
what does your user need? Give people what
they need, even if they don't necessarily
know that that's what they need. This requires
the kind of empathy that I was talking about
a few minutes ago. You can't figure out what
people need unless you understand them.
And you can't understand them unless you know
them. One thing, as an aside that I'll suggest,
is that focus groups are almost remarkable
in how useless they are no matter what you're
trying to study because focus groups assume
that people can tell you what's wrong and
what's right.
And in general, people can't tell you what's
wrong and what's right. They don't understand
themselves well enough to be helpful even
if they're trying to be. You have to watch
what people do and not so much what people
say. Keep an eye always on developing technology
that is values-driven.
Keep an eye always on what the telos, what
the goal, what the purpose of the organization
is. That needs always to be in mind. And what's
important here is that it needs to be embodied
in the day to day practices of the people
who are actually doing the work.
These great speeches that CEOs make about
how they're interested in serving the community
are received with complete cynicism by their
workforces who know that they're going to
be expected to make margins, quarter by quarter,
in their area. And the CEO isn't gonna give
a damn how those margins get made as long
as they get made.
So, the trick is to make sure that the telos
of the organization, the mission of the organization,
is actually embodied in the day-to-day practices
of the organization. And lastly, fail early
and often. I gather this is not foreign to
people who work at Google.
There's an enormous benefit to failure. Trial
and error and mentoring by people who have
already failed early and often are, as far
as I know, the only route to wise decisions
and wise practices. And so, you need a culture
in which people are encouraged to fail.
With, I should point out, somebody looking
over their shoulder to make sure that none
of these failures are completely catastrophic.
I don't think surgical residents should be
given the freedom to fail when they start
doing open-heart surgery. You wanna make sure
that patients don't die en route to becoming
skilled surgeons.
The last point I'll make is that I think that
if we refocus ourselves on the importance
of wisdom, it can become self-sustaining.
Once we are clued in to why wisdom is important
to get us the schools, the hospitals, the
technology companies that we want and need,
it will keep itself going and here's why.
What we know about happiness and its determinants
is that there are two most important determinants
of happiness; the two most important determinants
of well-being are close connections to other
people, a network of meaningful and close
social relations, and meaning and purpose
in your daily work.
Freud had it right, though for the wrong reasons,
when he said that life is all about love and
work. Life is pretty much all about love and
work. And what Ken Sharp and I believe is
that you can't have good, meaningful, close
relations to other people and you can't do
meaningful, purpose-driven work unless you
have developed the practical wisdom that enables
you to figure out what people need and then
how to provide it.
So once people become wise, their work goes
better, their relationships go better, they
get more and more eager to get up in the morning
and do tomorrow more or less what they've
done today. And that makes it self-sustaining.
Thank you very much.
[applause]
>>Female Presenter: Are there any questions?
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #4: Thanks very much
for this wonderful talk. I was just thinking
about a talk that Jared Diamond gave, I think
in 2003 or 2004.
>>Barry Schwartz: Who? I missed the name?
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #4: Jared Diamond,
>>Barry Schwartz: Uh huh.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #4: who wrote "Guns,
Germs, and Steel"
>>Barry Schwartz: Yep.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #4: about the signs
that our civilization is headed toward collapse
based on historical evidence of how. And I'm
wondering if you look at the power structures
that have prevented that suppress this kind
of wisdom, that create all of these rules,
do you think it's possible that changes can
come about within these power structures,
or only after they collapse? Can wisdom become
a way a society is run?
>>Barry Schwartz: So, that's a great question.
I wish I knew with confidence the answer.
What I can say is in the book we talk at some
length about two kinds of people who work
within these systems and acknowledge in their
own terms, not in ours, that they're not working.
We talk about people who are canny outlaws.
They follow the rules because of somebody
looking over their shoulders, but the find
ways, like teachers, will follow the scripted
curriculum, but they'll do it at double-time.
And so, they squirrel away ten minutes here
and twenty minutes there or a half hour there
and in that time that they have saved, they
teach the stuff the way they think it should
be taught.
They prep kids to take standardized tests
and they'll tell them, "Listen, if you get
a question about this, don't give the answer
I just told you 'cause you'll be marked wrong.
Give this answer instead." So these are people
who are trying to do it alone. Any my view
is that this is not sustainable.
Eventually, they burn out in discouragement,
or they get caught and they get fired. More
hopeful are the people we call "system changers."
These are people working within the practice
of law, the practice of medicine, who see
that they are not training their new doctors
and lawyers well and are trying to create
systems for training, medical training, that
are completely different from the ones that
they grew up with.
And some of these things are popping up in
highly prestigious places as pilot programs.
Harvard has one. UCSF has one. Students get
contact with patients early. They see the
same small set of patients for a whole year,
so that they actually get to understand what
it means to be sick in the context of living
an often complex and difficult life.
They have lots and lots of interaction with
mentors who are looking over their shoulders,
letting them make the first pass in their
decision, but correcting them when they get
it wrong. The students in these programs love
them. They're incredibly difficult to get
into.
Everybody wants to get into this program,
but they only accommodate 15 or 20 people.
Now my hope is that what will happen over
time when the evidence comes in that the people
who get trained in this way become better
lawyers, teachers, and so on is that it will
transform the way in which medical and legal
education occur.
That's a big step, but it's not enough because
if they then enter the structure of their
profession and all of the incentives that
are presently in place continue to be in place,
this seems to me almost certain, It's almost
certainly gonna happen that all of the good
stuff that they've learned gets destroyed,
or at least tackled, challenged.
So, I hope you don't need the systems to collapse
completely so that you can build new ones
on the ruins. I'm hoping that it's possible
to build new systems on, not quite ruins,
but clearly defective existing ones. But I
don't know. I just don't know. There's an
ideological component to this.
Everyone thinks that the way to get what you
want is to make it worth people's while. That's
wrong. Doctors want when people enter medical
school wanting to be doctors for the right
reason. Everyone? No. Almost everyone? Yes.
You don't need to make it worth their while.
You need to get out of their damn way so they
can do it the right way for the right reason
on their own. And as long as we're wedded
to this ideology that comes from economics
that nobody ever does anything except for
some self-interested outcome, we'll never
redesign systems in the way that we need to.
So, optimistic I'm not. But I'm also not hopeless.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #5: Have you looked
at the differences between the US and other
countries with respect to this practical wisdom
topic?
>>Barry Schwartz: The answer to that is no.
We haven't really done the kind of careful
and systematic inquiry. What we have done
is look at examples, books and articles, written
about the guide of the actual practice of
teaching in medicine or the way in which teachers
and doctors are trained and use these examples
to illustrate, we think often vividly, what's
the wrong way and what's the right way to
engage in these practices.
But we haven't done anything remotely like
counting. The sense I get is that the problem
is less acute in Europe than it is the United
States, partly because one principle driver
of all this obsession with rules is the threat
of being sued. And that's less of an issue.
The culture of litigiousness that is characteristic
of the United States is close to unique to
the United States. So there's a little bit
more room in Europe for people to spread their
wings and take a chance without worrying that
the world will come crashing down around them.
But I think the ideology that you have to
make it worth people's while to get them to
do anything is pretty much as pervasive there
as it is in the US. And that's a major obstacle
that needs to be overcome.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #6: Hi Professor Schwartz.
I was actually in your Practical Wisdom seminar
when you taught it with--
>>Barry Schwartz: With Ken?
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #6: Ken Sharpe, yeah.
>>Barry Schwartz: Who are you?
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #6: Meesha.
>>Barry Schwartz: Ah.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #6: Yeah.
>>Barry Schwartz: Were you in the first one?
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #6: I was in the first
one. Yeah, yeah. So it's awesome to see the
>>Barry Schwartz: Did I get it right?
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #6: Yeah. I remember
you walking through all the different industries--lawyers
and doctors and pointing all that out. So
I'm looking forward to looking at the book.
>>Barry Schwartz: Thanks.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #6: The question I
had was about opting people in automatically,
going back to that.
>>Barry Schwartz: Yep.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #6: I think Google
does a lot of this. We opt people into advertising
on ad networks that they don't know about,
hopefully in their best interest. Privacy
issues as well. How does paternalism and practical
wisdom help us walk that line in those areas
particularly?
>>Barry Schwartz: This is an incredibly interesting
and complicated question. I'll give you a
brief pass at it. Sunstein and Thaler, when
they wrote their book called "Nudge" were
very insistent and I think it must be because
Thaler is an economist, that you don't nudge
people in a direction because it's good for
society or even because it's good for them.
You nudge them only when you have independent
evidence that it's what they want. So, if
you didn't know that 96% of Americans approved
of organ donation, it'd be hard to justify
moving to an opt-out system of organ donation.
That seems to me to be way too cautious.
So, I think it's appropriate to nudge people
in directions that are good for them, whether
they want it or not, or that are good for
society. The critical thing is that you are
not forcing people. People can opt out. If
they don't opt out, what they end up getting
and what they end up doing makes them better
off and all the rest of us better off.
But what exactly is the level of privacy for
example, that's the right level of privacy
to serve the interest of individuals and the
interest of the collective? That's a really,
really hard question to answer. But I think
it's one that's worth asking because defaults
have incredible, I mean, Facebook is a classic
example of the power of default. People didn't
realize that they were parading all of their
weapons and their body parts for the entire
world to see. They just thought that their
closest 12 to 15 thousand friends would know
about their unusual habits and hobbies.
It turns out no. Everybody, including anyone
who might employ them got to find out about
that. It wasn't deliberate on the part of
the people who did this. It was the default.
So, there are some defaults that are better
than others. And it takes a lot of work and
understanding of people to figure out which
defaults are the right ones.
The other thing I'll say is this. It is absolutely
crucial, in my mind, that Google's integrity
be unimpeachable so that when people see the
ranking of hits when they type in a search
term, they know that there is no pecuniary
interest driving that hierarchy. It is instead
the result of a very smart algorithm that
will only get smarter and that is designed
to serve what the client's needs are.
That's a very precious resource to guard and
nurture, because once you lose that sense
on the part of the public that you're in it
for the public's good, it'll take you a generation
to recapture it.
My own concern is that Google has gotten a
little bit careless about preserving the unimpeachability
of its integrity in the service of a business
model that pushes, obviously pushes in a different
direction. So, I don't think you can put a
price on that.
I think its value is essentially infinite
and it is something that is really easy to
lose and then hard to recapture. That help?
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #6: Yeah. Thank you.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #7: So, I have one
other question came to mind, which is both
for me and for a co-worker of mine about rewards
for children for trying to get children to
follow, for example, using the toilet and
not in diapers.
A co-worker of mine gives his son chocolate
chips and his wife says, "It's terrible. You
should never do that. That means they'll always
be looking for a reward." Any thoughts on
that?
>>Barry Schwartz: This is why there's nothing
in life that requires more wisdom than being
a parent. It is terrible to use rewards to
get your kid toilet trained, unless you're
desperate and nothing else works.
It's terrible to use rewards to get kids to
do their homework, unless you're desperate
and nothing else works. A lot of the seemingly,
from my point of view, foolish efforts to
incentivize school performance that school
systems are now using, this is not the first
thing they rush to.
They rush to it basically in desperation.
If there was some other way to do it, they
couldn't figure out what that was or they
didn't have the resources. So, they're gonna
try to improve the quality of what the amount
that kids learn any damn way they can.
And I think sometimes parents are desperate
enough that they do what they know in some
sense is the wrong thing, because the goal
is important enough that you just have to
get it. And then you'll worry about the negative
consequences of getting it in the wrong way
further down the road.
So again, I don't know, you shouldn't. Some
rewards are worse than others. Chocolate chips
are worse than praise, for example. There
is some reason to think that recognition is
a less tainting reward than material rewards
are. But even recognition is problematic because
kids start doing work in school because they
wanna be recognized, not because they wanna
learn.
So, they're interested in approval and not
mastery. And as the work gets harder, you
see dramatic differences. Kids who are interested
in approval choose easy things to work on
so that they'll get approval. Kids who are
interested in mastery are eager to fail so
they'll get smarter.
Carol Dweck at Stanford has done brilliant,
brilliant research for 25 years on this distinction
and how at roughly third or fourth grade,
kids who are performing at exactly the same
level start to diverge. The mastery oriented
ones take off and the performance oriented
ones basically flat line.
So, a little too much recognition and praise
may have the effect of turning your kid into
somebody who always wants a pat on the head
with unfortunate consequences down the road.
But there's no formula. There just isn't a
formula for being a parent, a friend, a doctor,
or anything. We good? Thank you all.
[applause]
Thanks very much.